so right over here i have the type of
spinner that you might see in a child's
game you can see there's seven equally
likely possibilities let's see there's
one two three four five six seven
equally likely possibilities it looks
like in four of them you you've spun an
elephant two of them you have this mouse
running away from something and then in
one of them you have this this monkey
doing some type of acrobatics
fair enough
now let's let's pose ourselves an
interesting question
at least i think it's an interesting
question let's say we were to spin the
spinner 210 times
so we're going to spin
we're going to spin that spinner 210
times
and i want you to make a prediction
i want you to predict
the number of times
number of times
we get an elephant
we
get an elephant number of times
we get an elephant out of the 210 times
so why don't you have a go at it
all right so you've i'm assuming like
always pause the video and then had a
try so one one way to think about is
well for one spin what is the
probability of getting an elephant
so let's do this one spin
so for one spin
what is the probability of getting
an elephant
well let's see there are we have already
talked about this is a fair spinner
there are seven equally likely
possibilities
and then how many involve getting an
elephant well so we have one
two
three four
four out of the seven equally likely
possibilities involve us getting an
elephant
so one reasonable thing to do and this
is actually what i would do is go look
for 4 7's probability means i should
expect that 4 7 of the time
over especially if i'm doing a lot of
these experience if i'm doing it over
and over and over again it's a
reasonable expectation that hey four
sevenths of the time i will get an
elephant i've just calculated the
theoretical probability here based on
this being a fair spinner and that
should inform that if i were to do a
bunch of experiments that four sevenths
of the time that that i should see
me getting the elephant
so it would be reasonable or reasonable
prediction to say look i'm gonna i'm
gonna spin this thing 210 times
and i would expect that 4 7 of those 210
times i would get an elephant
and so
let's think about what this is 210 times
4 7 210 divided by 7 is 30 30 times 40
is 120. so 120 times
my prediction or maybe your prediction
was this as well but i think it's a
reasonable prediction is that if i spin
it 100 if i spin it 210 times then i'm
going to get an elephant 120 times
that's very important to think about
what this is saying and this is not
saying
is it possible that i get an elephant
121 times or maybe 119 times sure sure
it's completely reasonable that you
might get something different than this
in fact there's some probability that
you get no elephant that you know if you
consider getting an elephant lucky that
you just you just happen to keep landing
on the monkey or one of the mice now
it's a very low probability that that
would happen if you've done it 210 times
but it is it is possible so it's
important to realize that this is just a
pretty there's actually a possibility
that you might get an elephant on all
210 spins once again that's a low
probability but it is possible so this
isn't saying that this is you're
definitely going to get it 110 you're
definitely going to get the elephant 120
times in fact it's very reasonable that
you might get the elephant 123 times or
128 times or 110 times or even 90 times
these are all completely reasonable
things to to happen all you would say is
that look if i had to predict it this
out of all of the different you know i
can i can get an i can get the elephant
anywhere between 0 and 210 times
out of all of those possibilities before
i even start spinning i'll say okay you
know i think that this is the this is
the most reasonable one that i'm going
to get 4 7 of the time
but it's not saying that hey yeah this
is this it's not saying that i'm i'm
definitely going to get it 120 times
it's not saying that 118
times or
129 times aren't
reasonably possible as well it's just
saying look this is a reasonable
prediction i'm using the experimental
probability it's 4 7's probability and
so if i'm going to do something 210
times well i could expect that it's
going to happen 4 7 of the time i don't
know for sure that it's going to happen
4 7 of the time but that is a reasonable
prediction to make